[Music]
hello out there it's us again back for
the matinee show where we're talking
about some new movies yeah three of them
yeah this week we had one in the theater
one on Netflix and one on shutter so we
got off now the first one we're gonna
talk about is called hog Azusa
yeah heathens curse yeah now technically
this actually came out it premiered at a
film festival in 2017 and then it got a
wide release in its native Germany in
2018 but it didn't come to Netflix until
April of this year which is 2019 so it's
fair game
yeah you know this is a kind of like a
an art movie it's an art film you know
yeah it's doing what the Germans do
imagine if some Germans made Mandy it's
an odd movie it really wasn't to my
tastes but Jenny liked it is about
witches yeah and a bunch of weird [ __ ]
goes down in it it's very weird movie
it's shot weird it's got kind of a slow
pacing and I was trying to creepy the
[ __ ] out in the way that a German might
try to creep you out is it creepy German
is this Buddhist route as hell I was
expecting Deezer to jump up [ __ ]
touch my monkey love it it could have
happened at any moment but it was creepy
it might have daddies sucking like
cannibalism and weird which is coming
back to the dead and I guess possession
and rust roots bleeding and drinking up
blood and loving goats a little too much
yeah and then they kill the goat that
they had sex with that's just weird [ __ ]
man
and it's what you know woman doing you
know well female witch yeah yeah hard
time following it actually Mike tonight
okay I'm gonna say this right now now
okay the the movie was directed by a guy
named Lucas feigl Feld and this is
actually his first movie this was his
film school graduation project and it
was most
crowdfunded and you can tell that it's
very influenced by the 2016 instant
classic the which you know it in the
sense that it's set during that time
period and it's but this one said in the
Alps now if you liked the very slow burn
like creepy atmospheric kind of deal
that the witch had then you will
probably like this as well because it's
kind of similar I will say that it
doesn't have quite as strong a narrative
you know through line as you which does
it almost doesn't have any damn dialogue
yeah it's like it's almost entirely
silent they're gonna skip moving again
moving the camera we can't through a
change it's just what she's like well
you know he's like I'm gonna push that
right off of there she says she needs
she looked at me like what room I need
more room over you guys yeah so yeah and
this is like it's it's basically I'm
gonna say it's like a very atmospheric
it's almost more like a mood piece or
like a tone poem then yeah houki then
then an actual narrative like I said
it's very much an art flick but if you
liked the witch then you will probably
like this as well it's basically it's
set in the 15th century it's set in the
Alps and it's in like four parts like
it's like four chapters kind of and it
mostly you've centers around this woman
named al Brune and she's a little girl
at the beginning and like her mom gets
like bubonic plague or some [ __ ] like
that but there's like some witchy [ __ ]
going on with her mom but then the the
next three are like other you know
facets of her life like you know the
second chapter was like 15 15 years
later so she's grown up and she still
lives on this like remote little farm by
herself except somehow she's had a baby
but they never tell you where it comes
from now there are a couple of
implications like something that one of
the other characters says at one point
and one of those two things could be
true I'm not sure if they're implying
like a supernatural thing or if they're
implying that they think it's a
supernatural thing and they're like
making it because I feel like the guy
that made it like I read a little bit of
an interview
with him and he was like he really was
interested in the idea not so much of
like which is being real but of people
being like this woman is like really
like shunned by like her community
because they thought that her mom was a
witch and they think she's a witch too
and they're like if she is mistreated
enough will she just bust out and do the
[ __ ] that they're accusing her of doing
you know what I mean so I think that was
he was interested in exploring that
aspect you know and and maybe she had
like some mental health issues and stuff
too and he was like kind of maybe making
a statement about how all of these
things and the time period and the
people's superstitions and stuff could
like come together and make a monster
when maybe she wouldn't have been if
people had treated her better you know
what I mean
I kind of I kind of feel like that was
the direction that he was going in if
you're into this kind of movie you'd
probably like it ever think I think you
know if you like me and you know me you
know no to me it came off as kind of
pretentious there's a lot of really slow
phases kind of like you know it's like
it's like [ __ ] the Germans do and it's
and we're you know there's not a lot of
dialogue very much dialogue and it's
just kind of like okay I know next I
know dude I know and it's just showing
you some stuff and I know now all sudden
and then it's some really weird [ __ ]
would happen yeah like what the [ __ ] I
was like don't like paying attention to
something else and they're like what is
she doing with that goat it is like that
oh it's not my it's not to my taste I
like a fast paced story yeah this is not
that yeah I look at that fast paced
story where a lot of [ __ ] happens on a
lot of people say some [ __ ] this isn't
some plus so he punches somebody else
blows up and it's like stays on fire for
a while and he's got this like badass
car and her titties are giant you know
cars
yeah it's just just like elements that
kind of yeah he's like the opposite this
is no lobster yeah I like certain
elements that put me into the movie yeah
yeah like I said this is very much I
mean I really liked it because I'm like
saying cuz I didn't really know where it
was gonna go like I just saw it like
recommended and it's you know came to
Netflix this year and I was like okay
well I'm gonna sit down and watch this
one so I didn't really know what was
gonna happen so I'm just like watching
it and I'm just like it was like kind of
creepy and stuff like that and then I'm
like what the [ __ ] it's like you know
what I mean it's very much like that it
has it did kind of give me a little bit
of a Mandy vibe yeah the difference is
is that the pacing on Mandy was quicker
is quicker so I'm going like what what
No oh man oh dude you know I mean it's
it's keeping me into the story this is
kinda it's too slow this is beast more
light yeah the guy that did Mandy the
other movie that he did the first movie
they didn't beyond beyond the black
rainbow this is paste more like that
because that movie was like was kind of
like this and there was hardly any
dialogue and like they weren't entirely
sure what was happening but there was
like a lot of like moody creative kind
of [ __ ] it's just a very and it is weird
it's like a really just a weird like
tone poem here's the thing sometimes
when I think of a slow movie I think
movie has a whole lot of talking in it
there's none of it's important or it's
important but you don't give a [ __ ] and
there's I I get a lot of that from
movies where there's a lot there's a lot
of stuff happening but I don't give a
[ __ ]
it all just depends on what this topic
is and how it's handled in a tone of the
movie in this one it's not like it's so
slow cuz it's jam-packed a useless stuff
the reason it felt slow to me is that
each shot lingered it's very long again
for a long time just on somebody's face
or on the [ __ ] wood line or something
and it did kind of have a score that's
trying to creep you out yeah I liked the
score for this yeah but the problem is
it's not effective with me yeah just the
way I'm built I'm like so what yeah so
what so what now if you pick up the pace
a little bit faster so I don't get bored
with it because you know I don't want to
say that I have a tense
goldfish I don't you know I mean it's I
don't even think it's as good as it's
not a go yes I don't feel that I have a
short attention span what it is is I
just have a limited amount of patience
for a director I think that's what it is
yeah you know what I mean they're
getting all into the project because
they're making it yeah but I'm just
sitting there kind of forced to watch it
half the time I'm watching a movie that
I really didn't want to watch I'm
watching it for the show it's kind of
like my job so it's already you know
mood has a lot to do with it yeah it has
a lot to do it the way you see these
movies okay so I would imagine if I was
big into witches all right and what's
[ __ ] jacked for this movie maybe I
would have reacted to a little bit
better yeah
but because I'm pretty much indifferent
to most movies they're the directors
already working from a disadvantage with
me you know I mean so you're not the
best person to be reviewing movies this
way not this you know I think so because
I think I represent that just average
guy yeah that's true ya know so I'm not
even the average film go or a movie go
I'm just average guy
yeah so if I'd like it chances are a lot
of other people would like it I can tell
you I can call the winner Jenny yeah I
called many winners when we saw mrs.
that's that [ __ ] matter fabulous
movie that movie went on to make a lot
of money because it can appeal to a dope
you know basic yeah but I'm not smart
enough to know what they're doing you
know I know a good movie want to see it
this is not a bad movie it's just an art
movie yeah and if that's if you know
you're getting into and you like that
kind of thing and me my god if you liked
the witch if you liked beyond the black
Rambo if you like like experimental yeah
like mood piece type of horror movies
then you will probably dig this cuz I
thought it was pretty cool and like
Mandy was also a horror movie yeah
but man I liked the pacing and the
dialogue yeah and in the and the the the
context that the movies coming at you
from this yeah
you know I mean they got the whole acid
angle going and everything I really like
that yeah this one had a little bit of
this yeah because it had like she took
like a mushroom and then she was kind of
like tripping out and stuff like that
but not too not as like over the top as
well my point of view it was defeating
itself had he made those shots a little
shorter and trimmed maybe 15 20 minutes
of the movie out a basic kind of like
just long shots the pacing of the movie
might have actually been a little more
interesting - yeah like this this room I
reminded me a little bit of midsummer as
well
yeah slightly a little bit mid this this
one was seemed more what's it good to
what I'm looking for more pompous in a
way yeah it's taken itself [ __ ]
seriously you know midsummer I kind of
had that same you know air about it to
me too you know but not as much yeah I
like it a lot people hated midsummer
evidently it everybody hated it I hadn't
heard that I'd heard it evidently most
people I listened to early liked it I
saw a lot of reviewers on YouTube just
saying it was just a worst horror movie
of the year I don't think it was for a
general audience I mean I understood
walking about because I grew up
listening to [ __ ] death and June and
current 93 and all that you know weird
you know early neat you know pagan goth
you know if I can was I said tough
post-industrial gothic folk type stuff
you know so I knew the context but allah
healed oh yeah you know but see that's
the big bro in there and he's [ __ ]
swimmin well yeah you know but you know
that's true a lot of it but I let
honestly I like that the thing that I
like about these guys that I liked about
midsummer that I liked about this movie
I said I liked the people because it's
very easy just to make like you know a
very boilerplate slasher movie that you
know people might like because they're
like oh that's fun and stuff like that
but it's much harder to make one so so I
admire people that want to do something
different even if it's a failure it's
more interesting to me than just another
one of those like cookie cutter kind of
you know slasher means that they make so
many of and I've seen a lot of them and
some of them
okay but it's like you don't really
remember them like we even we even
reviewed a couple of them on here like
mercy black and stuff like that which
they're not bad movies they're just
another one it's a lot of there are a
lot of them like that so I always
respect when somebody tries to do
something different
yeah the word I was in for was
pretentious this movie kind of has a
pretentious air a bit yeah
alright more so than midsummer alright
and I think Mandy didn't really have a
pretentious vibe yeah Mandy was not
pretentious not at all alright but
they're all kind of art beyond the black
rainbow twas a tad was it but I still I
still liked it it was weird as [ __ ] but
yeah but I didn't get a protect I did
that was way more pretentious than Mandy
was I'm looking at thumbs up just
depends on what you're looking but it
depends on yeah and I'm just gonna say
this is not definitely not gonna be like
for a general audience but if you like
more like art house right before like
more like a mood piece something it's
like I said there's not it's there
there's not much dialogue but if you
liked the witch then I feel like you
will probably like this because yes it
was just the genre of the movie yeah I'm
not big into that genre you know that
art how that artsy fartsy pretentious
[ __ ] yeah but it was good yeah if that's
what you're into I like that if it's
done well yeah but I've seen some that I
was just kind of like no thanks I mean
I'm a lot more open like I like stupid
movies I like smart because I like all
kind of movies I don't care what they
are it's like so I'll just watch them
I'm just like alright just show me what
you got and it's like most of the time
I'll sit through the whole thing yeah
unless it's really really offensive or
really really boring there's something
like that but that rarely happens I
usually give it a chance because I don't
like to [ __ ] on movies that I haven't
you know that I haven't watched all the
way through some people might like this
movie yeah and like I said it's actually
gotten really good reviews I think it's
like 95 percent or something like that
so like a lot of the critic critics
really like and a lot of horror fans
really like it like I said if you know
what you're getting into if you like
midsummer you'd probably like yeah if
you like midsummer if you like the witch
if you like that kind of thing then you
will probably take this as well so it's
on shudder I think now so or it was when
we watched it a couple days ago so if
you have a shudder or you could rent it
or whatever so go check it out
okay and the next movie we're going to
be discussing was one that we saw on
Netflix but also made a brief theatrical
run in the United States I don't know if
it played at our local it I remember
seeing it on the app but that doesn't
mean we never got a date for it it did
so it never played at our theater and I
wanted to see it yeah
wandering earth though wandering
wandering earth it was a chance Chinese
science fiction adventure movie yes and
I thought I was gonna have some do with
aliens and [ __ ] like that you know going
to other planets but no not not at all
it's it's so it's a wild movie god glad
that I didn't see it in the theater here
because have we seen it in the theater
they would show us the the English dub I
hope not but that's what would happen
yeah what the English dub sucked what
yeah this is what happened like we cuz
we missed it in the theater right it's
like if it did play here it was like a
day and like we missed it I don't even
know if it played our theatre or not but
like so we start where I was like oh
look they have it on Netflix and we
started watching it and it was English
dub that I'm like oh man it's like I
hate dubbing it drives me up the wall
she switched it to China and then I was
like oh well maybe they'll let me so I
switched it back to that I liked it much
better it like even made the movie look
better look and sound better I mean
everything you want us you want to kind
of watch it with Chinese dialogue which
the acting is really comes off a lot
better in Chinese it does that's what
Chinese dialogue with English subs and
movie kicked ass mad it was [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] bizarre it's this is kind of
like China proven that they can make a
gigantic science fiction move along the
lines of like a Marvel like a big-ass
jet Pohlman right this is like this is
but this was like right up there by
Avengers in game and it's made like
Marvel movie money yeah like when we
looked at up Wikipedia not a knighted
States but worldwide but yeah this is
made like seven or million dollars it's
like the second highest-grossing movie
in China of like all-time yeah it's
imagine you took 2001 a Space Odyssey
2010 a Space Odyssey Blade Runner
Prometheus 8 oh you wanted to
and Empire Strikes Back and push that
all down into one movie and made it a
Star Trek movie his bizarre AB and they
threw everything into this movie
everything it works though it were it
what the what do you call it the special
effects looks great yeah everything this
it was actually kind of rational in
terms of like certain parts of the
science and actually kind of work well
they had like a whole bunch of like real
scientists like yeah Sultan's on this
that's why yeah here's the problem the
earth start it's way in the future and
it turns out that 61 at the 2061
turns out that the earth is gonna seem
if the Sun is gonna go Nova I think was
gonna was gonna go know about yeah yeah
it was gonna like expand and suck in the
whole entire solar system because
something went wrong with its fission
somehow it doesn't really it'll explain
it but I don't really remember exactly
what yeah cuz I think I was too
distracted that was before I turned the
dubbing off now a rational person would
say let's make some damn spaceships and
get [ __ ] out [ __ ] out you're not dealing
with rational people you deal with
Chinese people they decide in this movie
to just move the earth well everyone on
earth everyone yeah this is the Chinese
tennis story those very elite Chinese
come up with some [ __ ] like this and
it's [ __ ] epic they build these earth
engines and they just build engines on
the surface of the earth just on one
side of the sphere and they start moving
the dam all right we're gonna weigh yeah
they're gonna move it out of the stealth
system yeah of course this is gonna [ __ ]
up the ecology of the earth Bab that you
know but they have all the animals and
all the plants and all the DNA and all
the people go subterranean to live
inside the earth which is login they
live in like bunkers yes it's moving
around the atmosphere is kind of it
looks like it's getting pulled off of it
when it's moving anyway they're gonna go
on like this look and they're gonna move
it like 4.5 light years away a resume
yeah it's a 4.5 yeah why not take like
2,500 years yeah 2500 generational thing
was all going good you know they were in
thinking of a lot of more in hypersleep
weren't they um they were well there was
two things there was like the earth no
yeah wandering earth that is you're
wondering earth yeah and then there was
like a um like a Space Station there was
following following it like - like
I didn't sir like just to make sure
nothing went wrong and right and then he
had like a bunch of [ __ ] in the yeah in
the course we're having a movie so
shit's going wrong and what's going to
happen for some strange reason it goes
right by Jupiter and it and it started
the earth starts to get pulled into
Jupiter something went wrong with one of
the little with some of the engines that
were on the surface of the earth and I
think they're gonna slingshot around
Jupiter was the I yeah yeah but it but
the the to get more speed but what ended
up happening is some went wrong and it's
starting to get pulled in so they got in
this is this big adventure of them
trying to get the engines back online
and get the damn earth pointed in the
right direction and pull it out of
Jupiter pull it out of there loose
atmosphere and it's doing all kinds of
weird [ __ ] to the earth it's a [ __ ]
disaster movie yeah it's like it does
that I would probably call it a disaster
movie more than a sign yet I mean
obviously it's still science fiction
because you know it's an earth and it's
going through an ex-patient the chant
really spoil it that's just a setup yeah
all right um I really enjoyed the movie
that acting was good had a bunch of
heroic Chinese characters in it yeah
like a plucky band of yeah you had also
had people from other nations that were
in it yes exactly
yeah Russians and yeah they showed the
Americans doing [ __ ] it's a couple of
Brits in there but yeah it was uh it was
cool man I mean the sets were [ __ ]
awesome it looked like you'd look like
it looks fantastic it looked it looked
like Prometheus a lot Prometheus in you
can see them that was like a big
implication covenant and it looked like
certain parts of like the one when they
went in there where the the Earth engine
looked just like the core of the Death
Star you notice that it did yeah and
then you could tell they Cana
the hypersleep chambers look like
something directly out of alien or oh
and uh the ship's computer was like how
yeah and it was doing a bunch of house
stuff and biology lives look yeah and
then there was like a bunch of stuff
that you saw like in 2010 which is a
good movie if you haven't seen that one
that was cool yeah just it was cool and
and one of the things I liked about it
is
there's they're obviously kind of like
setting it up for a couple more films
yeah where they're gonna go hopefully
you know they'll run into some aliens or
something well yeah yeah that's enough
that's what I would like to see I like I
mean okay so this was actually based on
a novella which I haven't read and
they're at were actually some changes I
don't think in the novella I don't think
like all that Jupiter [ __ ] happened I
think like there was other things going
on um but they added the Jupiter's
because you know they needed like more
and more like horrible things together
like as the movie went on because like
everything was a disaster yeah
everything and like so many people like
ended up dying itself but I like the
fact the guy that made the movie a huge
fan of James Cameron and he wanted to I
think he wanted to show that one that
you know Chinese cinema that they could
make a movie just like you know one of
the big like tentpole movies like a
Marvel movie or Star Wars or something
like that and he also wanted to show
he's like I wanted to show regular
people all coming together and like
saving their instead of superheroes
right which I agree with that which I
thought that was pretty cool there's
like yeah they're just like regular
people and like you know and they have
to do like all these really difficult
things to like save everybody yeah
mankind is totally getting [ __ ] up
everybody all of mankind is on this
earth ship well yeah everything working
together - for the scene it's not like
you could go anyplace if you didn't
agree with the plan they're like where
you gonna go yeah you're all just
sacrificing himself to save the earth in
certain parts and is his badass flick
flick get up my favorite character was
the grandpa they were all good I liked
grandpa they have it was so crotch when
any one of the characters has a blog
white guy who's Chinese Chinese Chinese
the effort you know also you get to see
somebody barfi which and look at him
he's a white guy's he looks at me it
looks like a white guy to me yeah I
thought white guy speaking fluent
Chinese it was really fine
so it the thing you know is that I ended
up really liking this movie a lot but I
think when we first started watching it
and we watched probably like the first
10 or 15 minutes with the dubbing and I
was like I don't know from you listen
through all this because like I said the
only time I can tolerate dubbing is in
Italian giallo movies or kung fu movies
yeah it's like then
doesn't bother me but any other movie
like any foreign language movie I do not
want ya dubbing it drives me up the
[ __ ] wall and it went in when the
dubbing was on it kind of reminded me of
a cross between like a touhou to
Godzilla movie
yeah and and maybe remember battle
beyond the stars well yeah message from
space yeah the Japanese Star Wars
dubbing is not good and it made and it
made the whole so in a way like the
first 10-15 minutes I was like I don't
think I'm gonna like this movie just
because the dubbing was so bad but then
I was like oh die I can change about you
Mandarin with the English Chinese and
then I was like oh okay this movie so
it's like it's funny how much of an
effect yeah that had because it took so
it took me a long time to like get into
the movie yeah
looks like everyone's wearing spacesuits
and I'm like wait is that that guy in
the spacesuit or is that the other guy
cuz everybody has spacesuits on but like
so but so it took me a long time to like
kind of catch the wave of the movie and
like get into the characters and stuff
just cuz I was like befuddled by the
dumb English it look like yeah I think
this should look like a cheap fake movie
like I said it even made it look cheaper
yes when the dubbing was done soon as
you get put the Chinese dialogue it all
says always a real movie oh there
actually is a really good actors like
and you can hear them really talking
yeah but yeah but imagine most of the
movies we like they get dubbed out into
other languages that foreigners see they
probably had that same effect where man
that was a shitty movie I know now I
know it's like I wonder if somebody's
ever like written a like scholarly paper
on this kind of [ __ ] because it really
did affect my enjoyment of the movie
like just the dubbing like once the
dubbing was off and I could read the
subtitles I'm like oh my god this is
actually a really good yeah I imagine
Star Wars just looks like [ __ ] when it's
dubbed it just makes every it cheapens
everything yeah I mean I would much
rather read the movie cuz I'm [ __ ]
half deaf anyway so it's like it's good
if I can read it cuz then I even turn on
I can turn on closed captioning on
English language the face to be honest
with you because I'm afraid of an abyss
but yeah I recommend the movie I mean
even even a chucklehead blood like this
movie it's just fun movie yeah it
shouldn't like I said it's disaster
after disaster and it's just like a
bunch of plucky little characters right
impact coming together and like no
trying to get through all this [ __ ]
horrible [ __ ] that's happening to the
earth
weird political messages because it's
not for us as Chinese stuff well like I
said it's a very simple happy like it's
it there's like some family stuff there
with like you know the grandpa and the
grandsons and then the dad and like
they're kind of estranged and stuff so
there's that well I had one message man
be brave yeah that's really well like I
said everybody's got we're all on the
same boat I mean literally in this movie
we're all in the same boat so
everybody's getting a kind Hitchin yeah
yeah so I liked that kind of message
about it and like I said all the
disasters and stuff like that was really
like cool and epic really good special
effects and like I said I guess
everybody really loved this movie too
because I didn't realize it made so much
money because it played here like it
didn't even play here I don't think yeah
but yeah it made like [ __ ] tons of money
so yeah it's on Netflix at the moment so
probably you should go check it out if
you like that time of it kind of thing
okay third movie we saw this week we
actually just saw it in the theater it
is scary stories to tell in the dark
damn decent movie pretty decent yeah if
you liked it the new version it it's as
good as that just not quite as hard yeah
I would
it does have a very good vintage feel
because it's taking place in the 1960s
1968 it said and it kind of reminds me
of a really good older Stephen King
movie yeah it did have that vibe it kind
of has that vibe it's it didn't really
it didn't scare me
but I enjoyed it yeah I enjoyed it it
was a lot harder than saying like house
with a clock in its walls
yeah well this gave me a similar vibe to
that or maybe like the goosebumps movie
but a lot scarier like it was creepy
ergo warrior um not as not as say scary
as per se la Llorona or you know that
whole universe of stuff it had a retro
feel to it kind of like say like
poltergeist one yeah from that era
something like that it's kind of like
harkening back to the 80s when they did
movies because this is a movie that's
very much geared toward a younger
audience
it's pg-13 but they I mean they got away
with a lot of [ __ ] yeah the guy was a
lot for a pg-13 movie I'm you know it's
not a bloodbath or nothing like that but
it was approaching the new hit series
yeah there's approach in that I mean it
is more geared toward adults is that
more intense and that's like scary or
more jokes this one though like I said
this is this is very much it's set in
1968 but it get it gave me a very much
like an 80s feel feel where where you'd
have these movies that were aimed toward
you know tweens or young teenagers but
were like super super scary it was the
same kind of writing and direction that
you would do for an 80s movie but it you
could tell was modern technology doing
all the rendering and it's taking place
in the 60s and it kind of it's kind of
weird because you know if here in
Florida basically everything's new
all right but if you live in the Midwest
or you live in some of the other cities
you see some this old architecture
that's still around yeah some of these
buildings are around from the 60s and
stuff and it's a trip seeing that old
stuff I forgot what it was like like
something's taking place in in high
schools that are kind of like the ones I
went to in Michigan yeah yeah back in
the 80s and it's just kind of good to
see they recreated that whole world they
really did you had cars and everything
and it's like the guy that drives a
guillermo del toro did the screenplay
and he produced it also but it was
directed by Andrey over Dahl who also
did troll hunter and the autopsy of Jane
Doe which are both also excellent movies
if you haven't seen them yeah um like I
said this very much gave me a look cuz
remember we saw that goosebumps too
movie yeah this is kind of like that but
not as goofy yeah not good and creepier
I mean in anybody of a certain age that
grew up lakes is about our age yeah um
well know that this is based on scary
stories still in the dark you know the
anthology book by um Alvin Schwartz how
you read it she did and yeah there were
actually three of them I think I only
read the first one or maybe the first in
a second there were actually three books
the first one came out in 1981 now this
book is this movie is very much based on
the first one now what he decided to do
because when they first optioned the
rights to the book and I think this is
like going back like five years or
something like that they were first
talking about making this an anthology
movie but then Guillermo del Toro was
like you know he's like whenever I see a
horror anthology it's like the horror
anthology movie is only as good as its
worst story right so and it's never
gonna be any better than its best like
you know there's always one that's super
good and then the rest merges met so he
wanted to do something more that was
more like a narrative so even though
this does have aspects of some of the
stories that were in the first volume
like the you know the big toe and that
weird that weird one that might I did
jangly man and all that kind of stuff so
even though that does have that it's
kind of like folded into like this
larger frame story about this group of
like dorky little kids who I mean the
mainly little kids are high school
well they're yeah they're high school or
I guess yeah they're supposed to be like
14 15 16 something like high school
they're wild you know they're doing the
feral [ __ ] we did when their drive-ins
and everything and sneaking into
abandoned houses and done dog [ __ ] on
each other and just thoughts like dog
[ __ ] yeah we're back funny [ __ ] but yeah
the girl at this who's like the main
character her character's name is Stella
um I think in the movie like Tom leaned
over and whispered it's like hey that's
your spirit because she's like this
little girl she had this geeky just
glasses and like she's super super into
horror and she got like all these old
like horror movie poster girl she's
little built little right and it's it's
the good thing about it is that it's not
little kids because they're doing stuff
in a drive-in and they're going into
houses and stuff and so they're they're
the characters are old enough to be
doing what it is that they're supposed
to be doing yeah and face to face the
[ __ ] monsters yeah you know and what
I did what I liked about it say opposed
to say I put this on pause like like you
said like a creek show and things like
that around that kind of a movie but
they did it in a different way now
creepy she has a bunch of different
stories and then as a wraparound story
yeah they do it like that what they did
was this whole story is about a monster
they can tell you a bunch of different
other stories
yeah and it's kind of like telling you
the story of how you're gonna die like
it's writing it into the book so the
movie has a probably four or five
monsters in it yeah each one is totally
different it's a totally different
experience so just a different way of
doing a kind of like an anthology in a
way but it's a continuing story yes same
characters with the same characters
awesome character and they kind of like
they didn't go super into this but I
think that there was like a mention or
two of this in there but I think that
the monsters that attacked each
particular kid because they each had
their own like fate that was gonna like
befall them they're like custom-made
they were custom-made for the kid like
it had to do with a story that you read
before
that like traumatized she was a kid or
something I think there was really only
one mention of that like later on like
one guy one of the kids like said he had
like a dream and yes then later you know
it comes true and stuff things that they
worried about yeah and then like at the
end you know the one character Ramon who
says oh this was a story that I heard
you know the jangly man's story that was
the story that had scared him as a kid
now interestingly I had thought now
there is CGI in this like some of the
monsters but I didn't realize until I
was like looking it up and reading about
it that a lot of the monsters are not
CGI now the the jangly man at the end
some of that is CGI but the guy playing
that character is a contortionist
yeah he's do so yes so that's why so a
lot of the [ __ ] that he's doing is
that's like a real guy doing that and I
was like flabbergasted when I found out
about that but the monsters they did a
really good job and like I said if your
same age as me and you were into horror
which you know maybe a lot of you were
and read the first one of these books
the most famous thing about these books
probably even more than the stories was
the illustrations by Stephen Amell or
Gamal or however you pronounce his last
name like a lot of people that were kids
at the time like still remember like how
scary those illustrations were and they
did a good job of bringing those
illustrations to life because I mean the
thing is if they were black and white I
mean it's just black and white like
creepy I think they were like kind of
watercolor and ink and he did like these
really creepy like illustrations and
they did a really good job like doing
like a 3d rendering of those like on the
screen I think the corpse without the
toe was probably my favorite one
although I really liked that big pail
I liked him off fat well don't don't
don't don't spoil yeah well no some of
the ones they showed in the like like
the woman with the toe they showed yeah
a trailer but yeah so finished did it
hold up it was the book like that yeah
okay I mean like I said um I feel like
they might if this does well I feel like
they might do more because it open
because they left it open and the first
volume of scary stories to tell in the
dark which came out in 1981 have like 29
30 stories in it and in this one they
really only kind of did four or five of
them um you know just kind of in brief
sort of you know on there
you know periphery of what was going on
with the main story so I feel like
there's a lot they could do with this
yeah and um I kind of like I mean I
don't know it's I feel like some people
might have liked it better as an
anthology but I think it kind of works
better like this because you could
relate more to the central characters
and I don't know I just I liked that the
way that he structured it where you know
I mean this type this story could go on
like forever
yeah like each person because each
person is scared of a different thing
and it's like if this ghost like knows
what scares you and is writing a story
about what's gonna happen to you then
all of them are gonna be different so
you can do a lot with that yeah so I
kind of feel like maybe they should do
that and this movie is a really good one
and I think I might have said this too
about about when we reviewed the house
with a clock in its walls this is much
scarier than that although I loved that
movie because that's like that was like
a favorite book when I was a kid but
this is definitely something that if you
have like kids you know like 9 10 11 12
years old that are really into horror or
a look at that they would probably
really really dig that they had some
kids that age yeah I mean there was
actually the people in front of us have
yeah that of little girls probably like
six or seven she had her jammies on and
everything yeah I don't know if she
liked it or not I couldn't tell she
didn't scream her pretty quiet I guess
she was hurt deep it's it's a good movie
for all ages yeah um it's not like he
says it's not goofy it's not not like
the goosebumps yeah I know I didn't you
know it's funny cuz cuz the [ __ ] that
the characters say yeah but it's it's
not so scary that a little kid can't see
it yeah I mean it it might scare them I
think about their nobody we're not so
bad with it but not so bad that you know
if they wanted to run or anything that
it would like cause lifelong trauma to I
think I'd like that first episode of
that first movie from it yeah can't wait
to the second one it was a lot harder
yeah I like that's more like an adult
more like without but this is can't
compete with it yeah I would say just
like I said I'm surprised at how much do
we got rating yeah I'm surprised how
much because I was like pg-13 I thought
it was gonna come off like goose bumps
or like sick or like a kids movie
um not really not really it did but
there was a lot of like messed up stuff
I didn't get this mic on par long like
on par with an ad Stephen King film yeah
not like that and then like I said they
also said it in 1968 it was like a
background of like the Vietnam War and
stuff like that was gonna play it was
like a weird thing to say but that was
kind of in the background there but yeah
I mean I really liked it these the
characters you know the little four
characters at the center were likable
and all the monsters were cool and you
know take your kids to see it not know
if they're super little but you know
because it's it is pretty scary like for
a little kid but you know it's it's an
enjoyable family flick if your family is
all into horror and if you grew up
reading these books like I did you will
probably get the audience I think most
people read these books and they were
kids yeah it wasn't kids in the audience
yeah I mean other than the couple that
brought their little kid jammies like
most of us but it was mostly adults and
I feel like this was and I from what I
heard people talking about like after
the movie was over like they were
talking about how it compared like the
rocks and stuff but you know so check it
out if you like that kind of thing and
like I said take your kids to see it if
they're into horror and probably scare
the [ __ ] out of them and maybe they need
it
[Music]